People have asked me and I still take SAM.
E you take it everyday if you're like over 30,
take it everyday because it helps your body process um,
like the happy chemicals.
Because when you get old, it's a chemical that your body needs.
Your body only naturally.
There's no way to get it in food or supplement
in any other way other than like a supplement.
It doesn't. It's not naturally occurring.
Your body produces it,
but your body slows its production as you get older.
And sometimes as you're getting older,
you may feel like you're like feeling depressed or sad.
Or maybe not depressed,
just like melancholy,
just down blue.
I don't know what was going on.
If you could be low on SAM.
Even a lot of people don't know about it
cause a lot of people don't go to therapy,
but therapists are the one that tell you about it.
Or really, really good practitioner.
But whatever.
I did what? And I see there's no fucking ad,
there's no sponsored.
I don't know why women gotta hate on women making money.
But I'm not making money on this video.
I'm just recommending for you to be happy.